cannabis should be legalized to end the
embarrassment of domestic drugs policy
according to a cross-party group of MPs
they've estimated changing the UK's
drunks laws would bring in more than a
billion pounds a year for the Treasury
want to debate that were joined by the
Conservative MP turtle it Peter lilly
who's calling for the legalization of
cannabis he joins us from Westminster
and it'll bring in tax revenue from the
government that is true but but what
else do you think legalization would
really achieve well it will end the
greatest harm that the present situation
involves whereby people who do use
cannabis can only get it from illegal
gangs who often push them to take hard
drugs as well so we're pushing soft drug
users into the arms of hard drug pushers
and we're also creating a vast industry
for drug gangs which gives them a lot of
income which would be better channeled
through an illegal outlet taxed I'm not
in favor of encouraging cannabis use
I've never taken it myself and that's
probably why I've got a clear enough
head to see that our present policy
isn't working I mean you say that you
know that you have a clear enough head
and that you don't want to push people
into the hands of drug pushers but there
is a great deal of evidence that
starting using cannabis does lead to
other drugs and it's not just because
your pusher happens to sell more than
one kind of drug people want a different
hater
a bigger fix and cannabis has been shown
to then lead onto people becoming
addicted to other much much stronger
drugs and that's the argument why we
shouldn't legalize it isn't it I don't
think that is so in the Netherlands for
example
it's legal to use cannabis but as a
result people get it from legal outlets
and far fewer people in Holland go on
from using cannabis to using hard drugs
because they're not in contact with
people pushing those drugs do you have
any concerns that it's normalizing drug
use I mean this is drug use it's
something that we shouldn't be
encouraging full stop whether it's a
Class C drug across a or a B drug and by
making something like cannabis available
legally it is in the sense normalizing
it well I think it's important that we
recognize there's a difference between
things being right and then being lawful
lots of things which are wrong you know
I got dull try but we don't try and make
that illegal I'm not encouraging anyone
to use cannabis I wouldn't use it myself
I would discourage children from using
it but I think if we devote most of our
drug control resources to preventing
cannabis ineffectively we don't control
the hard drugs which do far more damage
having said that if it is legalized
there will be people who will say oh you
can get this legally this isn't illegal
this isn't bad for me I should be able
to use it and it makes it more normal
and it could lead to the numbers of
people taking cannabis increasing well
one's got to explain why in the
Netherlands fewer people use cannabis
than in this country even though it's
legally available we haven't succeeded
by making it illegal in stopping people
using it
we have discredited the law we've
created a vast industry for criminals
we've put people on the route from soft
drugs to hard drugs and we've avoided
having a potentially useful sense of
source of revenue for the government and
we haven't even made it available for
medical uses what about the school of
thought that because cannabis is illegal
that some people who would possibly use
it or fearful some people who want to
avoid prison or who want to avoid a
criminal record if they are caught with
it will go into rehabilitation and will
stop using it therefore the fact that it
is illegal is proving a deterrent to
some people well as I said there doesn't
seem to be over much evidence given that
in countries where it is legal the rate
of use is either lower or about the same
as in Britain and some people think even
the the tint a hint of illegality about
it adds a little you know interest and
excitement to young people to take it I
think it should still be wrong to sell
cannabis to underage people as it is to
sell alcohol and tobacco what do you
feel about the use of it for medicinal
purposes do you feel confident are you
comfortable that there's been enough
research done into the possible
positives and indeed negatives of
cannabis use for people who are using it
for illness well clearly if it's going
to be prescribed for medical purposes
then it should goes
all the tests of any other drug but if
people use it because it relaxes pain
and easy as they're suffering then and
it's in safe form then I see no harm in
that what about the health implications
a bit of people who have very very
adverse reactions to it there's a lot of
evidence that that young people young
men especially react very badly some of
them to taking marijuana especially the
strongest Skunk varieties and they can
lead to really significant mental health
problems whether or not it's people in
large numbers for the small numbers of
people who do take it it can have a
really really negative effect do you
still feel comfortable knowing that that
it could be legalized well one thing we
can do if we sell it legally is have
health warnings on it and at the places
where it's sold so that people have got
conditions with which it would react
adversely we'll be warned of it as
they're not at present doesn't stop
young people drinking or smoking though
does it they know that's bad for them
too but stop some of them you're not
allowed to sell alcohol and tobacco to
underage people you shouldn't be allowed
to sell cannabis or other drugs to them
either but we weren't entirely prevent
that and we certainly haven't prevented
it present so it's not as if the present
system was working okay pretty really
good to talk to you thanks very much
pleasure